samsung has just revealed the galaxy s21
smartphone lineup
and we've already pre-ordered our top
spec ultra model
so we figured we would see exactly how
it compares to apple's iphone 12 pro max
to see if we have a new flagship
smartphone king so in this video
i'm gonna go through all the specs i'm
gonna compare all the features
and i'm gonna look at the performance of
the new snapdragon 888 chip
compared to the a14 bionic in the iphone
12 pro max
to see if the new galaxy s29 ultra is
right for you
so let's jump right into it first off it
comes with a new design that's more
rounded than before
and the camera bump looks way different
being kind of built into the frame
to me it seems like they did this
because the camera bump is so massive
looking just as big as it was on the
note 20 ultra which was much thicker
than the one on the iphone 12 pro max
they're also going
all matte this year like this new black
matte finish
and i personally really like how it
looks and it should feel really good in
the hand as well
weighing just one gram heavier than the
iphone 12 pro max
the display this year is absolutely
killer it's 6.8 inches large
so just slightly bigger than apple's 6.7
inch display
but it features a higher 3200 by 1440
resolution
the main issue we had last year with the
s20 ultra
is that we had to lower the resolution
to use the 120
hertz refresh rate mode but on the s21
ultra
you get both 120 hertz and full res
at the same time and if you're worried
about battery life samsung
solved this issue by using adaptive
refresh rate
which automatically adjusts between 10
hertz and 120 hertz
depending on the content you're viewing
just like apple has been doing for years
with the pro motion tech in the ipad pro
this
is absolutely huge because you no longer
have to choose between resolution
and refresh rate while the iphone 12 pro
is still limited to 60 hertz which at
this point
is just embarrassing not only that but
the s21 ultra's display
can now reach 1500 nits while viewing
hdr content
compared to 1200 nits on the iphone so
based on all of that
the s21 ultra's display kills the
iphones
in basically every single way there's
just no competition here
as far as the battery the one on the
samsung is a much larger 5 000 milliamp
hours
so it should definitely last longer than
the one on the 12 pro max
even with 120hz mode enabled which is
very impressive
the s21 ultra will come with 128 gigs of
storage
and 12 gigs of ram at the base price
which is twice as much ram
as you get on the iphone and you can
even get up to 16 gigs of ram
if you buy the maxed out 512 gig model
but as we already know iphones are very
ram
efficient so we'll have to test it out
ourselves when we finally get our hands
on the s20 ultra
so subscribe right now if you want to
see that one of the biggest drawbacks to
the s21 ultra is that they finally
ditched
the micro sd card slot which was one of
the main reasons people
bought galaxy phones in the past and
just as expected
there is no longer a charger or earbuds
in the box
which is kind of funny because samsung
mocked apple for doing this on their
iphone 12 lineup but because of that
samsung was able to get the price down
to twelve hundred dollars instead of
last year's
fourteen hundred dollars for the s20
ultra which was definitely
way too expensive and led to a drop in
sales
now before i get into comparing the
chips i want to mention a few more spec
differences and features
as expected the s21 ultra gets both sub
6
and millimeter wave 5g but something new
this year is an
ultra wide band radio chip which apple
already introduced with the iphone 11
pro along with that they released their
new galaxy tags
which can be used to track devices and
items like your keys
and as we already know apple has had
their own version in the works for over
a year now
but it's still not released and this
ultra wideband chip will also give you
more features like using your phone
as your car key and samsung already
partnered with audi
bmw ford and genesis to get this feature
up and running on new cars
one major new feature is the addition of
wi-fi 6e
which is unique because it uses a brand
new frequency band
compared to wi-fi 6 on the iphone which
uses the existing bands
so keep in mind that you're going to
need a new wi-fi 6e router
if you want to take advantage of this
samsung is also for the first time
adding s pen support to the s21 ultra
so you no longer need to wait for the
note model if you really want that pen
but this time it doesn't fit into the
phone itself
so it doesn't have a little spring
loaded button on the bottom instead
samsung is selling a couple of cases
that have a slot to hold the s pen
but this can be an issue because the
case is gonna make it even more wide and
large
and some people just don't like using a
case the s pen isn't included in the box
it's actually a forty dollar purchase by
itself or you can get it bundled with a
case
for seventy dollars which isn't that bad
of a deal
and as we know the iphone still doesn't
support any type of stylus
probably because apple wants you to buy
an ipad on the side
to use the apple pencil and one more
thing the s21 ultra features qualcomm's
brand new under display fingerprint
sensor which is 1.77 times larger than
the previous one
and it should be faster as well this is
actually crazy because even the
old version was faster than face id with
the only issue being reliability
so the larger size should definitely
help with that
and we're really excited to test it out
again now let's finally get into
performance and compare the new
snapdragon
888 chip to apple's a14 bionic
in geekbench 5 the iphone is a massive
40
faster in terms of single core
performance which is gonna make it feel
very snappy for common tasks and in
multi-core the iphone is still around
nine percent faster
even with only six gigs of slower lp
ddr4x ram
compared to 12 gigs of lp ddr5 ram
on the samsung so it looks like the
snapdragon is still a bit behind
but it's still extremely fast with that
let's finally get into the cameras and
there are a ton of changes this year
with the s21 ultra it now has five
cameras total
including a 40 megapixel selfie camera
that destroys
the 12 megapixel selfie cam on the
iphone 12 pro max
just like it did before the main camera
on the s21 ultra still uses a 108
megapixel sensor
which utilizes binning if you don't want
to use that mode but a major difference
this year is the fact that it now uses a
laser autofocus system
which is extremely important because the
absolute biggest issue with last year's
s20 ultra
was major auto focusing problems laser
autofocus should now fix that
and according to unbox therapy's video
even the 8k
24 fps video mode utilizes this
so thankfully we can now finally use
this mode without having auto focus
issues
but it still looks like the optical
image stabilization
is turned off in this mode they've also
got a really handy video recording
feature this year
director's view which allows you to view
and switch between angles
on the fly while on the iphone you can't
even switch
from the rear camera to the selfie cam
while recording and now
the s21 ultra can finally record 4k
60fps video
on any of the four cameras just like the
iphone can
which was a big drawback last year with
the s20 ultra
and as far as the ultrawide camera it
features a 12 megapixel sensor
just like the one you get with the
iphone and now the s21 ultra has not one
but two telephoto cameras both with 10
megapixel sensors
with one of them being an optical 3x
zoom
with the other being an optical 10x zoom
this is actually a really good idea
because the 3x camera features a decent
f 2.4 aperture letting in a bunch of
light
while the 10x zoom has a really bad
f 4.9 aperture so it should only be used
exclusively for long range zoom shots
when you really need it now i don't know
if you know this
but last year's s20 ultra only actually
had
a 4x optical zoom lens even though they
advertised the crazy 100x space zoom
so the s21 should do a much better job
and it should absolutely smoke
the iphone 12 pro max which only has a
single
2.5 x telephoto lens so in terms of the
cameras
i honestly believe that the s21 ultra
will now smoke the iphone 12 pro max
in terms of camera quality no questions
asked
but of course we're gonna have to see
when we compare them later this month
when it gets released on the 29th so
with all of that
said i've got to say that at just a
hundred dollars more expensive
than the 12 pro max the new s21 ultra is
gonna be
the better flagship phone even if the
performance doesn't quite match up
the main drawback this year is the lack
of a micro sd card slot
so if that's a big deal for you let me
know down in the comment section below
and if you want to see our full
comparison and camera test videos
click that circle above to subscribe so
you don't miss out on that and be sure
to watch one of those two videos right
over there thanks for watching and we'll
see you in the next video